Unsere Rufe sind in den letzten
Jahren lauter geworden.
Die Rufe von uns Frauen nach Rechten
Chancen und Respekt.
Bewegungen wie #metoo haben
Millionen von uns auf die Strasse
gebracht und aufgezeigt,
dass Männer und Frauen immer noch
ungleich behandelt werden.
Was die Welt braucht, sind sichtbare
Frauen. Mächtige Frauen, wie
die Deutsche Verteidigungsministerin
Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer,
die eine Armee von rund 200'000
befehligt.
Der grösste Gender Gap, dem ich
in meinem Berufsalltag begegne, ist
die Abwesenheit von Frauen.
Und es ist die Tatsache, dass Frauen
nach wie vor deutlich schlechter
bezahlt sind als die männlichen
Kollegen.
Frauen wie Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin,
die sich alleine gegen den Sexismus
der Schweizer Medienbranche stellt
- und gewinnt.
Wenn ich die Zeitung lese, da
sind Frauen noch viel mehr
Dekoration und
spielen vor allem in der Werbung
mit. Und das stört mich.
Und Frauen wie die Schwedin Erika
Lust, die eine der letzten
Männerdomänen aufmischt: die
Pornographie.
Wenn wir über Sex reden, dann gibt
es auch heute noch einen grossen
Unterschied zwischen Männern und
Frauen.
Die sogenannte Orgasmus-Kluft.
Was man online sieht, auf den ganzen
Gratis-Pornoseiten, ist für Männer
gemacht. Nämlich sehr harte
vaginale Penetration.
Ich und die meisten Frauen da
draussen wissen, dass es für eine
Frau viel einfacher ist, zum
Orgasmus zu kommen, wenn wir unsere
Hand benutzen: durch
klitorale Stimulation.
Diese Frauen spielen die Hauptrolle
in dieser Serie. Weil sie aktiv dazu
beitragen, dass die Welt zu einem
gerechteren Ort wird.
Mein Name ist Patrizia Laeri.
Ich bin Ökonomin und Feministin.
Wir Frauen haben ein Geldproblem.
Wir verdienen weniger als Männer auf
gleichen Positionen.
Ich bin auch Mutter und kenne die
Belastung, die berufstätige Frauen
mit Kindern aushalten müssen.
Als Journalistin beschäftigt mich,
dass wir Frauen öffentlich viel
weniger sichtbar sind als Männer.
Zum Beispiel auf der grössten
Wissensplattform der Welt.
Man sieht ganz klar, Wikipedia hat
ein
Frauenproblem.
Es hat viel mehr männliche
Biografien als weibliche Biografien.
Auf Wikipedia finden sich mehr
Porno-Darstellerinnen als
Lyrikerinnen, hat eine Studie
2015 gezeigt.
Warum ist die Pornografie immer
noch eine solche Männerdomäne?
Und was ändert sich, wenn Frauen
mitmischen?
Hallo, mein Name ist Erika Lust
und ich bin eine
Erotik-Filmemacherin.
Antworten suchen wir bei der
Schwedin Erika Lust.
Sie produziert feministische
Pornografie und findet: wir
brauchen dringend andere Bilder von
Sexualität als diejenigen in
Mainstream-Pornos.
Eine Frau. Blond. Hautenges Kleid,
rote Lippen, Brüste wie
Wassermelonen.
Ein Penis. Ein Penis so gross wie der
eines Hengstes, zwischen ihren
geschürzten Lippen. Sie gibt ihm
einen Blowjob. Warum? Weil ihr dieser
nette Mann zu Hilfe kam, als sie eine
Autopanne hatte. Das ist
Pornografie. Und es ist Zeit, dass
sich Pornografie ändert!
Erika Lust gilt als die weltweit
erfolgreichste Produzentin
feministischer Pornografie.
Aber kann Pornografie
überhaupt feministisch sein?
Alice Schwarzer, und viele andere
Feministinnen, meinen: nein.
Dazu gehört auch die amerikanische
Anti-Porno Aktivistin Gail Dines.
Erika Lust ist nicht feministisch.
Sie ist eine Porno-Produzentin.
Sie nutzt Frauen aus, um ihren
Profit zu maximieren und um mit
ihren Körpern Geld zu verdienen
Die deutsche Laura Méritt
veranstaltet ein feministisches
Porno-Festival und sieht
diese Problematik auch.
Über 90 Prozent der pornografischen
Filme sind sexistisch, rassistisch,
ableistisch usw..
Die Arbeit von Erika Lust ordnet
sie aber anders ein.
Erika Lust hat eine sehr, sehr gute
Arbeit geleistet, weil sie es
wirklich schafft, die Leute
abzuholen, auf
eine sehr ästhetische Art und Weise,
so, dass Leute mitkriegen: "ah,
da gibt's einen ganz schönen Ansatz.
Das kann ich mir gut angucken."
Und auch Erika Lust selbst ist
der Meinung: klar ist nicht alles
perfekt in der Porno-Branche!
Ich würde es gerne sehen, wenn mehr
Frauen, mehr Menschen aus
der LGBTQI-Gemeinschaft
und mehr Menschen mit verschiedenen
ethnischen Hintergründen in das
Geschäft einsteigen würden.
Nicht nur als Darstellerinnen,
sondern indem sie Teil der Industrie
werden. Als Produzentinnen,
Vertreiberinnen und
Geschäftsführerinnen,
In diesem Film beleuchten wir
Erika Lusts Arbeit und gehen
einem der ältesten Streitpunkte der
feministischen Bewegung auf den
Grund: Kann Porno feministisch
sein?
Erika Lust lebt und arbeitet in
Barcelona.
Hier befindet sich auch der Sitz
Ihres Unternehmens "Lust
Productions".
Auf dem Weg dahin möchte Rosanna
Grüter, die Macherin dieses Films,
von mir wissen, wie viel ich denn
bereits weiss über die
Pornoindustrie.
Als Wirtschaftsjournalistin habe ich
mich dem Thema Pornografie natürlich
ganz anders angenähert bisher. Diese
multimilliarden Umsätze angeschaut,
diese monopolistischen
Strukturen und Machtballungen nur
einer Plattform in der
Erotik-Branche oder Pornoindustrie.
Und auch diese
kreativen Business-Modelle in der
digitalen Welt.
Und abgesehen von der ökonomischen
Seite des Business?
...ist es ganz eine neue
Welt für mich.
Und mich beschäftigt schon
auch, dass das Thema Pornografie
eben genau das Thema ist, was auch
die Frauenbewegungen, was auch den
Feminismus extrem spaltet.
Und natürlich: Auch ganz viele
Menschen haben ein moralisches
Problem damit.
Bist du ein bisschen aufgeregt?
Auf jeden Fall.
Das freut mich!
Aufgeregt bin ich vor allem, weil
ich keine Ahnung habe, was mich
in einer Porno-Produktionsfirma
erwartet.
Zeit, es herauszufinden.
Mein erster Eindruck: Bisher
entspricht hier nichts dem Image
einer schmuddeligen Branche.
Im Gegenteil!
"Lust Productions" scheint mir sehr
elegant.
Wenigstens von aussen.
Hallo, wir haben es endlich
geschafft!
Willkommen bei Lust.
Wie geht es dir?
Der Fokus von Erikas Schaffen ist
nicht zu übersehen.
Die Trophäen, die sie für Ihre
Filmarbeit bisher erhalten hat,
sprechen eine eindeutige
(oder zweideutige) Sprache.
Hier drinnen ist mein Büro.
Das ist also das Hauptquartier.
Das ist der Lust-Raum.
Wow, schau dir diese Decke an!
Du schaust bestimmt
ständig nach oben.
Ich schaue oft nach oben.
In dieser Wohnung lebte eine
aristokratische Familie.
Sie hatten sogar eine kleine
Kapelle. Und
schau, was ich damit gemacht habe!
Und dann ist es endlich Zeit dafür,
mit ein paar Klischees aufzuräumen.
Fangen wir an!
Ich wärme meine Stimme auf.
Machst du das nicht?
Wie müssen wir uns einen
gewöhnlichen Arbeitstag von dir
vorstellen?
Ein normaler Arbeitstag.
Die Leute stellen sich vermutlich
vor, dass ich ständig von Pornostars
umgeben bin und wir in Limousinen
herumfahren und Champagner trinken.
Mein Leben ist so, wie das der
meisten arbeitenden Frauen.
Ich verbringe viel Zeit am Computer.
Schreibe, kreiere,
schaue mir Filmmaterial an, lese
Ideen von anderen und schreibe
eigene Skripts. Aber
dann gibt es auch spezielle Tage,
an denen wir einen Film produzieren.
Diese Tage sind sehr intensiv
und wir versuchen dann, den
bestmöglichen Film in der
verfügbaren Zeit zu machen.
Du hörst dir etwas an.
Deshalb hörst du nicht, wenn sie ins
Geschäft kommen.
So können wir ihr Gespräch
aufnehmen, wenn sie über die
Hochzeit sprechen.
Sie suchen einen speziellen Sari.
An
solch speziellen Drehtagen, dürfen
TV-Teams normalerweise nicht dabei
sein. Für uns macht Erika aber
eine Ausnahme.
Mit ihren Darstellerinnen geht Erika
das Drehbuch durch und instruiert
ihr Team für die Dreharbeiten
später.
Der
Porno, der heute hier gedreht wird,
heißt "The Saree Shop".
Er basiert lose auf der erotischen
Fantasie einer Kundin.
Solche
verfilmt sie in ihrer Reihe
"XConfessions".
211 Fantasien
sind so bereits filmische Realität
geworden.
Erika, was erwartet uns heute?
Was du heute erwarten kannst, ist,
dass dieser Dreh fast gleich ist wie
jeder Indie-Filmdreh.
Mit dem einzigen Unterschied, dass
wir Sex filmen. Während
wir diese Sexszenen drehen, dürfen
nur Kamerafrau, Tontechniker,
Fotografin und Kameraassistenz
in unmittelbarer Nähe sein.
Das restliche Team steht hinter dem
Vorhang.
Wir stehen also nicht vor den
Darstellenden.
Ich finde wirklich, dass sie etwas
Freiraum brauchen, um diese
Intimität miteinander zu haben
und einen sicheren Ort zu schaffen.
Okay.
Gibt es noch weitere Regeln?
Wie soll ich mich verhalten?
Es gibt natürlich einige Regeln
bezüglich der Covid-Pandemie.
Ansonsten solltest du allen Menschen
mit Respekt begegnen.
Ganz normal.
So meine Lieben, ich bin schon zu
spät.
Ich sehe euch später, ok? Vielen
Dank!
Während Erika die Sex-Szenen
dreht, unterhalte ich mich mit zwei
Statistinnen.
Beide haben indische Wurzeln.
Für sie ist es darum ein fast
revolutionärer Akt, in einem Porno
von Erika Lust mitzuwirken,
wenn auch nur als Statistinnen.
Sex vor der Kamera haben sie keinen.
Was denkt ihr über die Mainstream
Pornoindustrie?
Wo ich herkomme, ist Sex und Liebe
ein Tabuthema.
Trotzdem schauen sich Männer diese
Pornos an und erwarten
von uns Frauen, dass wir uns so
verhalten.
Aber indische Frauen sind nicht so.
Wir wurden dazu erzogen, sehr
rein zu sein
und es hat eine ganz andere Dynamik,
wenn es von der Pornografie kommt.
Und das finde ich schrecklich.
Viele Jugendliche in Indien schauen
sich diese Art von Pornografie an
und das hat einen negativen Effekt.
Es gibt offensichtlich noch viel zu
tun. Ich denke, Erika Lust ebnet
den Weg, dass Frauen Sex gegenüber
offener sind.
Die Szenen mit Monali und Priya
werden als nächstes gedreht.
Und auch die Hauptdarstellerin des
Films ist gerade in der Maske.
Ihr Name ist Kali Sudhra und auch
für sie sind ihre indischen Wurzeln
ein großes Thema.
Ich komme ursprünglich aus Toronto,
lebe hier in Barcelona und bin
Pornodarstellerin. Ich habe
angefangen, in der Pornoindustrie zu
arbeiten, weil... Eigentlich hatte
ich die Idee in einem Sexshop. Ich
wollte einen Dildo kaufen und sah
mich mit einer Wand mit
ausschliesslich
weissen Dildos konfrontiert. Das hat
mich frustriert. Also habe ich den
Besitzer gefragt, ob er auch braune
Dildos habe. Und er hat sehr
unhöflich geantwortet: "Nein, warum?"
Das hat mich geärgert. Warum gibt
es hier nichts, was mich
repräsentiert?
Hallo Kali, schön dich
kennenzulernen.
Hallo, freut mich.
Du bist Co-Regisseurin und
Schauspielerin.
Das ist sehr besonders.
Ich finde, dass südasiatischen
Identitäten, besonders queere, nicht
genug repräsentiert sind.
Das wollte ich vor der Kamera
aufzeigen.
Aber ich wollte auch meine eigene
Geschichte erzählen.
Das war mein eigentliches Ziel.
Ich habe als Darstellerin angefangen
und dann realisiert, dass
südasiatischen Menschen vor der
Kamera zu integrieren nicht
genug ist.
Das hat mich dazu angetrieben, meine
eigenen Filmideen aufzuschreiben
und darüber zu sprechen.
Und du filmst selten mit Männern.
Wieso?
Ich
finde, dass queere Sexualitäten
fluid sind, und dass das Sex so
schön und organisch und
unkonventionell ist.
Wenn ich mit cis-Männern arbeite,
ist die Arbeit sehr stereotyp und
fast wie aus einem Handbuch.
Es
ist nicht so, dass ich per se nicht
mit Männern arbeiten will.
Es ist nur nicht meine erste Wahl.
Denkst du, dass Pornografie
feministisch sein kann?
Ja, sicher. Ich finde, jedes Genre,
sei es Film, Medien oder
Kunst, kann feministisch sein.
Bevor die Szene mit Kali, Monali und
Priya gedreht wird,
proben sie.
Lasst uns mit der Probe beginnen!
Die Hochzeit
ist in 2 Wochen und ich suche etwas
Elegantes.
Ich mag zu viele Farben, vielleicht
etwas in Blau- und Grüntönen?
Das ist von Anfang bis Schluss!
Im Gegensatz zum Mainstream-Porno
sind bei Erika Lust die weiblichen
Darstellerinnen nicht einfach
Sexobjekte, sondern selbstbestimmte
Frauen, die ihre eigene Lust
ausleben.
Und wie war das jetzt für dich?
Und wie war es für dich?
Hey, ich hab es mir so anders
vorgestellt! Obwohl
uns ja gesagt worden ist, es sei
anders, als wir es uns vorstellen,
von Erika.
Wir waren ja vorgewarnt.
Aber trotzdem hab ich mir das
irgendwie...
Ich habe auch nicht erwartet, dass
ich da wie mich fühle wie so
einem digitalen, hippen Start
Up!
Die sind alle so hip, gell!
Extrem! Hipster aus aller Welt,
junge, engagierte Leute,
die Witze reißen, die
socializen.
Ja, wirklich.
Ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt beide bei
einer Sexszene wirklich dabei
gewesen wären, dann wäre es schon
nochmal ein bisschen anders gewesen
wahrscheinlich.
Da durften wir ja auch nicht dabei
sein, oder. Aber wir haben schon
gemerkt, da kommt dann schon Stress
auf.
Aber wir haben trotzdem was gelernt,
oder?
Also die Erika, die ist dann schon...
im Regie führen...
Ja, da kann ich noch was lernen!
Einigen ist es vielleicht schon
vorher aufgefallen: Erika
Lust arbeitet an ihren Drehs beinahe
ausschliesslich mit Kamerafrauen
und Tontechnikerinnen zusammen.
Ich habe den Unterschied zwischen
Kamerafrauen und -Männern gesehen.
Wie sie den Fokus
unterschiedlich setzen.
So viele heterosexuelle Männer
filmen den weiblichen Körper,
denn das finden sie am schönsten.
Und darum haben wir dann Stunden um
Stunden an Material von weiblichen
Körpern.
In solchen Fällen fehlen mir dann
aber Aufnahmen des männlichen
Körpers.
Ich habe versucht, dies meinem Team
zu erklären, damit
wir ein ausgewogenes Verhältnis
an Bildmaterial haben
Mit einigen wenigen Männern arbeitet
Erika Lust dann aber doch zusammen,
allen voran mit ihrem Ehemann
Pablo Dobner.
Mit ihm hat sie ihre Firma vor 17
Jahren gegründet.
Bei einem Drink in ihrer
Lieblingsbar in Barcelona
erzählen mir die beiden, wie es dazu
kam und wie sie sich damals
kennengelernt haben.
Wir haben uns im Sommer 2000
kennengelernt.
Ich habe hier in Barcelona Spanisch
gelernt und als ich eines
Abends mit meiner Schwester und
einem Freund ausging, ist dieser
Herr aufgetaucht.
Und sie hat mich angesprochen. Das
verblüfft mich bis heute.
Normalerweise passiert das nicht.
Was hast du gedacht, als Erika dir
erzählte, was sie so macht?
Als ich sie kennengelernt habe, war
sie noch nicht DIE Erika Lust.
Sie war einfach eine Studentin.
Das war im Jahr 2000.
Erica hat ihren ersten Film im Jahr
2004 gedreht, als wir schon
vier Jahre zusammen waren.
Ich war sehr am Thema Sexualität
aus einer weiblichen Perspektive
interessiert.
Das war das Skript, welches ich
geschrieben habe.
Der Grund war: ich hatte damals
einen Blog, auf dem ich über Sex,
Feminismus, Filmproduktion
und Pornografie geschrieben habe.
Und dort habe ich dann auch meinen
ersten Kurzfilm "The Good Girl"
veröffentlicht.
Und in sehr kurzer Zeit hatte ich
zwei Millionen Downloads.
Und Leute haben
mir geschrieben: Erika, wir lieben
deinen Film!
Er ist komplett anders als alles,
was wir bisher gesehen haben.
Machst du bitte mehr Filme?
Wann machst du mehr Filme?
Und das war der Moment, in dem wir
zusammensassen und über diesen Plan
nachgedacht haben.
Der erste Film war nur ein
Experiment.
Ich hatte nie geplant, die Erika
Lust zu werden, die ich heute bin.
Es war ein
Filmstudium-Abschlussprojekt,
eigentlich.
Wie hat euer Umfeld darauf reagiert,
als ihr ins Pornogeschäft
eingestiegen seid?
Unsere Freunde sind die gleiche
Generation wie wir.
Das war also einfacher.
Für die Familie war es nicht so
einfach.
Heute akzeptieren sie es, weil Erika
letztes Jahr von der BBC zu einer
der einflussreichsten Frauen gewählt
wurde. Und sie hatte einen TED-Talk
gemacht und Bücher geschrieben und
wird sehr respektiert.
Und ich werde an Universitäten
eingeladen, um zu sprechen.
Ich denke, dass sie deshalb gemerkt
haben, dass das, was wir machen,
nichts Ekliges,
Anrüchiges oder Geschmackloses
ist, sondern
dass es sogar etwas Wichtiges ist.
Ich muss gestehen, ich
hatte selbst all diese Vorurteile
und bin sehr überrascht, dass es so
anders ist.
Aber woher kommt es, dass wir alle
diese vorgefassten Bilder
über Pornografie haben?
Ich glaube, das liegt daran,
dass 90 Prozent der Pornografie
sehr ähnlich ist.
Und wir machen etwas, das immer noch
recht neu ist.
Euer Erfolg kam sehr schnell.
Gab es aber nicht auch viele Hürden
zu überwinden?
Es ist immer eine Achterbahn.
Besonders, weil unsere Arbeit mit
keiner anderen Industrie zu
vergleichen ist.
Es gibt viele Hürden und Ängste
seitens der Gesellschaft.
Würdest du sagen, dass du ein
männlicher Feminist bist?
Ja, ich finde schon.
Ab und zu werde ich noch von meiner
Lehrerin korrigiert.
Aber ich habe natürlich viel
gelernt, seitdem ich Erica
kennengelernt habe.
Und jetzt haben wir zwei gemeinsame
Töchter, was mich zur Minderheit
in einem Haus voller Frauen macht.
Also passt du dich entweder an
oder du gehst unter.
Hier, in der Bar Paradiso.
Im Zentrum von Barcelona, haben
Erika und Pablo auch einen Film
gedreht.
"A lethal Femme fatale" heisst er -
eine tödliche Femme fatale.
Herzliches Beileid, Miss D. Wirklich?
Zum Wohl! Folgen sie mir in 5
Minuten!
Die Bar hat nämlich ein Geheimnis.
Hinter eine Wandattrappe
in der Toilette versteckt sich
ein weiteres Zimmer.
Jetzt kenne ich den Zugangscode!
Willkommen im geheimen Zimmer!
Erika und Pablo sind Teil des
sexpositiven Feminismus.
Demgegenüber steht die sogenannte
PorNo Bewegung, die Pornographie
konsequent als frauenfeindlich
ablehnt.
Aushängeschilder sind z.B.
die deutsche Aktivistin und
Verlegerin Alice Schwarzer.
Oder Gail Dines, die in den USA seit
Jahren gegen die sexistischen und
brutalen Praktiken in der
Mainstream-Pornografie kämpft.
Der Hauptinhalt auf fast allen
Webseiten ist "Gagging". Das ist,
wenn der
Mann seinen Penis so tief in ihren
Hals steckt, dass sie würgen muss,
beinahe bis zum Erbrechen.
Frauen wie Gail Dines stehen schnell
im Verdacht, Sex allgemein
negativ zu sehen.
Zu Unrecht, sagt sie.
Nebst der Art und Weise, wie Frauen
in Pornos behandelt werden,
kritisiert sie vor allem die
Kommerzialisierung der Lust.
Pornographie ist die
Industrialisierung von Sex.
Lassen Sie es mich so sagen:
Pornografie ist für Sex,
was McDonald's für Essen ist.
Da ist nichts Falsches
an Essen.
Das ist ein normales, wunderbares
menschliches
Erlebnis.
Aber an McDonald's, oder der
Fastfood-Industrie, ist vieles
falsch.
Wenn ich also sage, dass ich gegen
die Pornoindustrie bin, bin ich
nicht gegen Sex.
Ich bin gegen die Pornoindustrie.
Also die Lebensmittelindustrie kann
reguliert werden, aber die
Pornoindustrie nicht?
Doch, man kann sie auf viele Arten
regulieren, und wir müssen sie weg
regulieren! Etwa mit einer
Altersüberprüfung, bei der jeder
Nutzer von einer dritten Person
überprüft wird, bevor er auf
Porno-Websites zugreifen kann.
Dann brauchen wir Sammelklagen gegen
die Porno-Produzenten wegen
dem Schaden, den sie Darstellerinnen
zugefügt haben.
Die vielen Körperverletzungen und
Vergewaltigungen.
Die meisten Frauen werden auf dem
Porno Set vergewaltigt, auch wenn
sie eine Einverständniserklärung
unterschrieben haben.
Und über das Zivilgericht können wir
die Porno-Produzenten, so gut
es geht, finanziell ruinieren.
Das ist der stärkste Weg.
Die Pornografen
sind auf Geld aus.
Nicht Sex erregt sie, sondern Geld!
Wir kriegen sie über
ihre Bankkonten.
Ganz anders als Gail Dines sieht
das Laura Méritt.
Auch sie findet zwar, dass da
einiges im Argen liegt im
Sex-Business.
Allerdings begegnet sie dem Problem
auf eine andere Art.
In
ihrer Heimat Berlin betreibt sie
den ältesten Sexshop für Frauen
in Europa.
Dazu gehört auch ein kleines Museum.
Das ist also der
älteste Sexshop Europas.
Ja, das ist es.
Was ist das für eine Geschichte
dahinter?
Also, von dem Sexshop...
Natürlich, 30 Jahre habe ich
dieses Jahr eigentlich.
Jaaa!
Und klar, vor 30 Jahren gab
es relativ wenig für Frauen.
Und die Sexspielzeuge waren alle
sehr einseitig.
Mehr phallisch, schlechtes Material,
also
riechende Weichmacher und
diese ganzen Sachen.
Und hier das ist z.B.
ein ganz lustiges Teil, weil
das natürlich auch dazu
diente, die Hysterie zu bekämpfen.
Also wenn Frauen halt als hysterisch
eingestuft wurden, dann wurde
letztendlich eben auch ein Vibrator
eingesetzt.
Das ist jetzt so, ich mein, das ist
ein sehr, sehr, sehr
schweres Teil.
Und das sollte dann ja auch nicht
wirklich Freude machen, sondern das
wird dann halt irgendwie so...
bis du dann zu diesem hysterischen
Paroxysmus kommst.
Und dann ist
das erstmal auch wieder vorbei.
Dass das dann auch vermarktet wurde,
ist ja natürlich auch eine spannende
Sache. Also die Bekämpfung
der weiblichen Leiden, die ja erst
kreiert wurden, die Hysterie.
Und dann eben auch...
Haben sich die Frauen dadurch wieder
beruhigt?
Genau.
Okay.
Wunderbar!
Aber es gab viele, viele
Möglichkeiten, wie die Hysterie
bekämpft wurde.
Du findest ja eigentlich, dass viel
zu wenig Wissen über die Sexualität
da ist.
Was wissen wir denn nicht über die
weibliche und männliche Sexualität?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass wir
schon in der Anatomie anfangen
müssen. Also dass viel
- gerade über die weibliche Anatomie
- einfach noch nicht im
Allgemeinwissen angekommen ist.
Kannst du uns mal die Vulva
erklären?
Ja! Hier, das ist die wundervolle
Vulva. Das ist ein Kissen, das
meine Freundin Dorrie Lane gemacht
hat, weil sie festgestellt hat, dass
es eine mangelnde Sexualaufklärung
gibt.
Und hier, das hat sie halt ganz
schön gemacht, dass wir hier auch
mal die Haube sehen.
Und hier drunter haben wir diese
wunderschöne
Klit-Perle.
Aber dass da eine Haube drüber ist,
dass es äussere Lippen gibt,
dass es innere Lippen gibt,
dass die sich natürlich auch öffnen
können, dass wir hier sehen: aha,
das ist die Urinstelle...
Dann ist hier auch wunderschön
eingearbeitet: die G-Fläche... Und
überhaupt, dass das so ein super
schönes Innenleben ist
und die auch manchmal sagt: mir ist
das jetzt ist aber genug, und dann
macht sie die Lippen einfach immer
wieder zu.
Europas ersten Sexshop für Frauen
zu gründen war Laura Méritt aber
nicht genug.
Seit 2009 führt sie
ausserdem alle zwei Jahre die
feministische Pornoaward-Verleihung
PorYes
in Berlin durch.
Sie ist also eine absolute Expertin
in diesem Bereich.
Wann ist denn ein Porno
feministisch?
Also es gibt keine feministischen
Pornos in dem Sinne.
Wir haben Kriterien.
Wir haben drei Hauptkriterien.
Das eine wäre, dass einfach eine
Vielfalt an
Sexualität dabei ist.
Das heisst, alle Gender,
auch Frauen, sollten dabei zu
sehen sein, wie sie geniessen, wie
sie Sexualität leben.
Das zweite ist auch
Vielfalt an Körpern, an
Hintergründen, an Kulturen,
an Alter.
Also all diese Sachen, die wir
eigentlich sonst eher als Kategorie,
als Fetisch sehen, das wollen
wir einem Film sehen.
Und das dritte ist ganz klar
Fairness.
Zum einen hinter der Kamera,
also dass da auch ein gutes
Team ist. Aber das andere ist auch
vor der Kamera.
Das heißt, ich möchte sehen, wie
die Leute miteinander in Kontakt
sind. Also den Konsens.
Wie machen die den denn vor der
Kamera? Ich will das sehen.
Wie kommunizieren die?
Das sind die Hauptkriterien
von Feminismus,
nicht nur von Porno.
Diesen Anforderungen versucht auch
Erika Lust gerecht zu werden.
Auf ihre Webseite wird klar
ausgeschildert, welche Kriterien
für ihre Pornos gelten.
Besonders wichtig: die Performers
Bill of Rights, also die Rechte
und Pflichten, die für ihre
Darstellenden gelten.
Die Bill of Rights wird sowohl von
der darstellenden Person
als auch von ihr selbst
unterzeichnet.
Dennoch findet auch sie: da laufen
viele Dinge falsch in der
Pornobranche. Einige
davon lägen aber außerhalb ihrer
Macht.
Was ich oft sehe ist, dass die
Produktion zwar korrekt durchgeführt
wurde, das Filmmaterial
dann aber in die Marketingabteilung
kommt und dort plötzlich
nicht mehr ethisch korrekt
verarbeitet wird.
Zum Beispiel werden junge
Schauspielerinnen jünger vermarktet,
als sie tatsächlich sind.
Sie waren offensichtlich volljährig,
als sie den Film gedreht haben,
werden dann aber als junge Teenager
vermarktet.
Wenn wir über ethische Pornografie
reden, müssen wir uns vor Augen
führen, dass es mehrere Prozesse
gibt Die Produktion,
die Vermarktung und Distribution
sowie die Konsumation.
Es gibt viele Menschen, die
Pornografie auf eine unethische Art
und Weise konsumieren, indem
sie auf die kostenlosen Webseiten
gehen.
Wir müssen daran denken: wenn wir
auf diese Weise Pornografie
konsumieren, dann geben wir unsere
Stimme für unethische,
ausbeuterische
Produktionsbedingungen ab
Ob umsonst oder für Geld: die
Nachfrage nach Pornografie ist
gigantisch.
Ganze 25 Prozent
aller Suchanfragen im Internet
sind pornografischer Natur,
also jede vierte Suche.
Die restlichen 75 Prozent
beinhalten alles andere: Von
Wissensfragen über
Gebrauchsanweisungen bis hin zur
Suche nach Jobs und Wohnungen.
Die drei größten Porno Webseiten
xVideos, xHamster
und Pornhub erreichen monatlich
eine Reichweite von 1,5 Milliarden
Nutzern.
Was viele nicht wissen: Eine
einzige Firma kontrolliert einen
Grossteil der Branche.
Das luxemburgische Tech-Unternehmen
"Mindgeek".
Was "Mindgeek" so mächtig macht und
von anderen Anbietern unterscheidet:
Sie besitzen
nicht nur die Tube Sites, sondern
auch die Agenturen, welche Werbungen
auf solchen Kanälen schalten, sowie
viele Porno-Produktionsfirmen.
Man spricht in der Branche von
einem Monopol, welches für den
Wettbewerb sehr schädlich sei
und z.B.
die Löhne der Darstellenden zugrunde
gerichtet habe.
Bei Erika Lust muss für alle Filme
bezahlt werden,
weil sie ihre Performerinnen
anständig entlohnen will
und weil sie so sicher sein kann,
dass alle ihre Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer über 18 Jahre
alt sind.
So viele junge Menschen sind
Unmengen an Online-Pornografie
ausgesetzt, ohne die Barriere,
dass dafür bezahlt werden muss.
Das ist ein Problem, welches wir als
Gesellschaft diskutieren müssen.
Es hat schon unterschiedliche
Lösungsansätze aus diversen Ländern
gegeben.
In Grossbritannien zum Beispiel
wurde über eine mögliche
Altersidentifikation gesprochen.
Dies ist daran gescheitert, dass
die gleiche Firma, die auch die
meisten Websites betreibt,
für die Verarbeitung der Daten
zuständig gewesen wäre.
Und diese Firma hätte somit Zugang
zu vielen privaten Informationen
gehabt.
Auch darauf, welche Pornos online
geschaut werden.
Es ist also recht schwierig.
Ja, sehr.
Erika Lust ist Mutter von zwei
Mädchen.
Wie leicht Kinder Zugang zu
pornografischen Inhalten im Internet
haben, ist darum für sie auch
privat ein großes Thema.
Von den 12 bis 13 Jährigen
geben 18 Prozent an,
bereits Pornos gesehen zu haben.
Bei den 14 bis 15 jährigen
sind es 38 Prozent
und bei den 16 bis 17-Jährigen
die Hälfte.
Wie sehr das Thema mich als Mutter
beschäftigt, will Rosanna Grüter
von mir wissen.
Am liebsten verdrängt man das
natürlich.
Aber machen wir uns nichts
vor. Aufklärung
- oder das, was Sie über Sex lernen
- wird mehrheitlich
im Internet stattfinden und was Sie
da an Pornos sehen.
Sprichst du mit deinen Kindern
über Pornografie?
Ja, da hast du mich jetzt ertappt.
Das ist ja so ein Thema, das schiebt
man immer wieder ein bisschen raus
und verdrängt es auch.
Meine Kinder sind wirklich auch noch
sehr verspielt für ihr Alter.
Und man hat so das Gefühl,
man gibt sie so aus
einer heilen Welt raus.
Aber gleichzeitig haben die
wirklich schon Internetzugang.
Sie lernen Medienkompetenz
in der Schule und die werden
früher oder später ganz sicher auf
Pornos stoßen.
Es ist einfach auch wichtig, dass
man es früh thematisiert.
Wir dürfen das nicht unterschätzen.
Welche Tipps mir eine
Porno-Produzentin wohl diesbezüglich
geben kann?
Als Mutter von drei
Kindern erhoffe ich mir Rat von
dir, wie man mit Kindern über
Pornografie sprechen kann und
wie man sie darauf am besten
vorbereitet.
Das ist ein ernstes und schwieriges
Thema.
Vor ein paar Jahren haben wir das
Projekt "The Porn Conversation"
gestartet.
Wir haben Artikel und Videos von
Experten gesammelt und drei
verschiedene PDF-Leitfäden
hochgeladen, je nachdem, wie
alt ihr Kind ist.
Diese Leitfäden erklären, wie
man diese Gespräche beginnen kann.
Ich glaube aber, am wichtigsten ist
das Bewusstsein, dass man diesen
Gesprächen nicht aus dem Weg gehen
kann.
Vor allem müssen wir unseren Kindern
erklären, dass Pornografie
nur für Erwachsene ist.
Sie müssen verstehen, dass Porno
fiktiv ist. Genauso,
wie Superman Fiktion ist.
Es gibt keinen Menschen, der
wirklich fliegen kann!
Ein Rat, der auch für uns
Erwachsenen gilt.
Denn auch auf uns kann Pornografie
negative Auswirkungen haben.
Wie negativ, wird allerdings
häufig übertrieben.
Das findet auf alle Fälle Madita
Oeming. Sie ist
Kulturwissenschaftlerin und
fokussiert in ihrer Forschung
auf Pornografie.
Wir wollen von ihr wissen, warum die
Wirkung von Pornos ein so
umstrittenes Thema ist.
Es gibt sehr viele Mythen rund um
Pornografie.
Es gibt sehr viel Angst rund um
Pornografie und es gibt auch
sehr wenig differenzierte
Berichterstattung darüber.
Und am Ende ist natürlich
der Punkt, wo die breitere
Gesellschaft und die Erkenntnisse
aus der Forschung zusammenkommen,
sind oft die Medien. Und die
sind zum Teil sehr
undifferenziert und sehr
voreingenommen.
Und das heisst, da sind oft sehr
vereinfachte Annahmen über
Pornografie im Umlauf.
Was sind so die Haarsträubendsten?
Also z.B.
ein Klassiker, den man immer wieder
hört, ist, dass Porno zu
Erektionsstörungen führt.
Etwas, was gerade in letzter Zeit
sehr häufig durch die Medien
gegangen ist. Man kann aber nicht
sagen, dass das wissenschaftlich
bisher belegbar ist.
Also was Studien herausgefunden
haben, sind nur Korrelationen,
also dass ein Zusammenhang besteht,
aber keine Kausalität.
Das ist natürlich auch ganz
schwierig nachzuweisen, denn das
würde ja bedeuten, dass man jeden
Faktor ausser Pornografie
ausschließen müsste im
eigenen Umfeld und in der
eigentlichen Entwicklung.
Und eine andere große Panik um
Pornografie ist, dass ausschließlich
Männer Pornos konsumieren.
Also ich erlebe immer wieder
Fassungslosigkeit, wenn
ich entweder von mir spreche oder
von anderen Frauen, die Pornos
konsumieren. Also das ist in unserer
Gesellschaft noch nicht angekommen,
dass auch das
eine Realität ist. Es ist zwar
durchaus der Fall, dass das Publikum
immer noch hauptsächlich aus Männern
besteht, aber eben nicht
ausschließlich.
Auch die sozialen Medien haben
ein gespaltenes Verhältnis zur
Pornografie.
Pablo Dobner, der Mann von Erika,
ist verantwortlich für die
verschiedenen Social Media-Kanäle
von "Lust Productions".
Oft würden ihre Inhalte zensiert
oder sogar gesperrt, sagt er.
Zu Unrecht, denn im Gegensatz zu
Anderen seien ihre Inhalte
nicht sexistisch.
Ein gutes Beispiel
ist dieses Benutzerkonto von einem
Ex-Soldaten der Marineinfanterie.
Er hat 32 Millionen Follower
und die Art, wie er seine Beziehung
zu Frauen und Sexualität darstellt,
ist perfekt für Instagram.
Für ihn dreht sich alles um Orgien
mit jungen Frauen.
Wie er seine Hand zwischen ihre
Beine legt.
Oder wie er eine Frau als Tisch
nutzt, um seine Trophäen zu
präsentieren.
Oder um seine Waffen.
Ihm gefallen Frauen und Waffen.
Für uns ist so etwas schwierig.
Wenn wir nämlich die Beziehung
zwischen Frauen und Männern oder
zwischen Frauen und Frauen auf
respektvolle, schöne Art zeigen,
werden wir zensiert.
Und nicht nur wir haben dieses
Problem! Das ist ein
schönes Beispiel dafür, wie
Instagram entscheidet, was ihnen
passt und was nicht.
Dieses Bild wurde zensiert.
Danach haben sie sich zwar
entschuldigt, aber es zeigt trotzdem
wunderbar die männliche Perspektive,
die scheinbar ist: Hallo, hier
bin ich mit meinen Mädels und ich
begrapscht ihre Brüste.
Oder, wie Donald sagte,
ich begrapscht ihre Muschi.
Solche Sachen sind okay für diese
Firmen, aber all die anderen, neuen
Ansätze nicht.
Dieses Bild wurde ebenfalls
zensiert, weil diese Frauen nicht
rasiert sind.
Ein weiteres Beispiel: Diese Frau
wurde zensiert.
Aber wenn du so aussiehst, dann ist
es kein Problem.
Das ist, was heute passiert.
Es sind nicht viele Leute, die diese
Entscheidungen treffen.
Es sind amerikanische Unternehmen.
Einige wenige Leute aus Kalifornien.
Du sprichst über Zensur.
Was tut ihr dagegen?
Wir können laut werden.
Wir haben die Kampagne "Biased
Banning" gestartet, worin wir alles
zeigen, was aus dem Internet
entfernt wurde.
Wir wollen aufzeigen, dass es eine
versteckte Agenda gibt.
Diese Zensur zeigt uns eine
bestimmte Vision vom Leben auf
In Europa und anderen Teilen der
Welt waren wir schon mal an diesem
Punkt, als wir sagten: Diese
Ethnie ist gut und diese nicht.
Wir bewegen uns wieder in diese
Richtung.
Was wir machen können, ist
protestieren.
Denn um ihre Plattformen führt kein
Weg herum.
Mit den sozialen Medien steht Erika
häufig auf Kriegsfuss.
Das Geschäft läuft aber gut.
Immer mehr Menschen, Männer wie
Frauen, konsumieren nämlich ihre
Filme.
Ganze sechs Millionen Umsatz
macht Lust Productions mittlerweile
pro Jahr.
Du hast den Umsatz deiner Firma
innerhalb von zwei Jahren
verdoppelt.
Wie geht das?
Ich denke, dass wir Zuschauerinnen
angesprochen haben, welche sich
vorher nicht so wohl gefühlt haben
mit Pornografie.
Wir sprechen besonders Frauen an,
indem wir ihre Perspektive und ihre
Erfahrungen in unseren Pornos
berücksichtigen.
Ich habe aber auch gesehen,
wie sich cis-heterosexuelle Männer
verändern.
Ich bekomme ziemlich amüsante
E-Mails, in denen Sie mir schreiben:
Hey Erika,
du hast Pornografie für mich
zerstört.
Meine Antwort ist dann: Was?
Wieso habe ich Pornografie zerstört?
Ich hab doch nur mein Bestes
gegeben!
Und dann erklären sie mir: Weisst
du, ich habe Pornos online geschaut
und war zufrieden damit.
Ich habe gar nicht darüber
nachgedacht.
Und dann lese ich einen Artikel über
dich oder schaue deinen TED-Talk
oder ein Interview, und plötzlich
realisiere ich, dass ich das gar
nicht will.
Wenn
ich Pornos auf diesen gratis
Webseiten schaue und all diese
Taglines lese, die so schrecklich
über Frauen reden, dann unterstütze
ich diese Werte gar nicht.
Das bin gar nicht ich! Solche Pornos
will ich nicht mehr schauen.
Ich habe gesehen, wie Menschen ein
Bewusstsein entwickeln,
dass es ein Prozess ist und
dass wir Menschen fähig sind, uns
zu verändern.
Dass die Pornoindustrie oft
sexistisch ist, darüber sind
wir Frauen, die in dieser
Dokumentation mitwirken, uns einig.
Wir Konsumentinnen und Konsumenten
müssen anfangen, Pornos bewusster
zu schauen.
Wenn wir frauenverachtende
Darstellungen konsumieren und nicht
für Pornografie bezahlen, fördern
wir ausbeuterische
Produktionsbedingungen.
Aktivistinnen wie Gail Dines
versuchen, die Branche haftbar zu
machen, wenn zum Beispiel
körperliche Grenzen nicht
respektiert werden und sexuelle
Gewalt als selbstverständlich
dargestellt wird.
Und Produzentinnen wie
Erika Lust werden selber Teil der
Industrie und versuchen, diese
von innen heraus zu verändern.
Als Wirtschaftsjournalistin stimmt
für mich der letztere Weg.
Und dennoch bin ich der Meinung,
dass die Auseinandersetzung zwischen
PorYes und PorNo wichtig
ist.
Denn nur, wenn wir Frauen Teil der
Debatte sind, können wir diese
auch mitgestalten.
Und nur indem wir über Porno
sprechen, finden wir als
Gesellschaft den richtigen Umgang
damit.